The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
The first thing I
would like to tell you,
which I did not mention the
last time-- that in the reading
assignment, the syllabus that
we handed out-- and by the way,
does everybody have one?
If you don't, we have
some extras here.
You all have one?
Good.
Anyway, as you can
see on the first page,
there is a section called
preparatory reading.
So I would recommend that
if you can each time read
this recommended reading,
which is available, of course,
on the internet.
And that will make it easier
for you to follow the lecture,
because this course is both
in vision and audition,
and relies on imparting
a great many facts
about the workings
of these two systems.
And it's easier to be able to
memorize these facts by doing
the preparatory
reading, if you can.
All right, so today, then,
what we are going to do
is initially start to
talk about the layout
of the visual system.
And then we're going to talk
about the retina for much
of the course.
At the very end, we'll
talk a little bit
about the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
In each case, I
will try to tell you
about how some people
thought about things,
and what the progression
is of the discoveries that
have been made about
the visual system.
It is certainly an
area of research
which has been
incredibly successful,
and has resulted in
quite a number of Nobel
Prizes for the discoveries
that individuals
had made in uncovering the
workings of the system.
Furthermore, many of the
uncoverings that investigators
had done came about as
incredible surprises,
because so many of the
findings were quite unexpected.
And I will try to point these
things out during the course.
And my section, as
I mentioned before,
will consist of 12 lectures.
And then that will be
followed on October 23rd
by a midterm exam.
And again, to
reiterate, that's going
to consist of a series of
multiple-choice questions.
And then following
that, we'll move on
to talk about the
auditory system
that Chris Brown is going
to be presenting to you.
All right, so the first
thing I want to do,
then, is to talk about the basic
wiring of the visual system,
which in itself has yielded a
number of unexpected surprises,
and also raised some
interesting questions.
So what I want to
start with first of all
is that when you look
at some animals that
have sideways-looking eyes, like
the rabbit and most amphibians,
the two eyes look out in
two different directions--
to the left and to the right.
And that enables them to
see a very large portion
of the visual field.
And when that is the case,
as in this picture shown here
for the rabbit, what
you find is that there's
only a small area which
is seen by both eyes.
But then when we look at higher
mammals, and particularly
primates and humans,
what you find
is that there was a huge change
in the course of evolution,
bringing the eyes to the front.
Now that change is very
interesting, and we can ask,
why on earth did that happen?
Because it meant
that, obviously,
a human cannot see
behind themselves,
where these rabbits can
see a much larger portion
of the visual field.
And so you sacrificed
ability to see all the way
around the world for being
able to see with both eyes
to the front.
And so the question is,
why did this happen?
Now we are going to discuss
this in some detail,
because one of the prime
reasons-- I believe
at least-- that
this has happened
is to be able to process
information about depth better
than it can be done by
rabbits and other animals.
And so when we talk
about depth perception,
we are going to deal with
this issue in more detail.
Now if you look at an animal
like a rabbit, what you find--
and also animals which are,
as I've mentioned already,
that you also have in
fish and amphibians,
you have these
sideways looking eyes.
And now we can ask
the question, how
do these two eyes
make their connections
through the ganglion cells to
the central nervous system?
And that, in fact, was
quite an issue at one time,
believe it or not, before
anatomical techniques
became more sophisticated.
And the reason it
became an issue is
because it was discovered
predominantly, actually,
by Cajal, who I've mentioned
had received the Nobel Prize
for the beautiful work he
had done on not only vision,
but in general about the
nervous system, in 1906
with Golgi, he
discovered, as did
several other investigators,
that the optic nerve crosses
over at the so-called chiasm.
And so the input
from the left eye
projects into the right
half of the brain,
and from the right half to
the left half of the brain.
And that became a huge issue--
why on earth would this happen?
And we are going to deal
with this repeatedly.
It's a very interesting issue.
And even more
interesting is the fact
that when the eyes move to
the front, what happened
is that this kind of connection
became much more complicated.
But before I do that, let me
just say a few more words here.
First of all, that in
fish and amphibians,
you have a huge structure
called the optic tectum,
which is the primary visual
processing center in the brain.
And there is also the
lateral geniculate nucleus
of the thalamus
in these animals.
But that's quite small, and
not very well developed.
And there is a cortex
in these animals,
but it is, again, a
primitive area compared
to primates, for example.
And the lateral geniculate
nucleus projects to the cortex.
So the left cortex
in these animals
gets input from the right
eye, and the obverse
is the case for
the right cortex.
And so consequently,
this cortex is
this part of the visual
field, and this cortex
is this part of
the visual field.
It's almost like an inversion.
Now we come to what happened
as a result of the eyes
moving to the front.
When the eyes move to the front
in the course of evolution,
that necessitated a major
rewiring in the visual system.
So that's what we are going to
look at next, because that's
us.
All right, so what
we have here then,
we have the two eyes
looking to the front.
And imagine that these two
eyes are looking at something.
There's a dot here.
And both eyes are
looking at the same dot,
so that you only
see a single dot.
OK.
So now what happens is
really something surprising.
What happens is that the--
let me interrupt for a second
and tell you that imagine that
you cut your eye-- I mean,
don't do it-- but imagine that
you cut your eye vertically
in half, each eye, OK?
And that means that each
eye has, if you will,
a nasal half and a
temporal half, all right?
So here we have the two eyes.
Here's the left eye.
And what we have is a nasal
half, projects across,
and the same thing is
true for the right eye--
projects across.
But now if you look at
the temporal hemiretinae--
hemiretinae, remember
that's the word for it--
something very
interesting happens.
The temporal hemiretinae
don't cross over,
but they remain
on the same side.
So we have a color code here
that the red parts project
across, and the black parts also
project across from one eye,
but stay ipsilateral
for the other eye.
So you say, my god,
why did this happen?
What on earth is going on?
And then if you study this, you
realize that this is actually
one of the few
truly logical things
that you encounter when
you study the brain.
Many of the things
you study in the brain
don't seem to be too
logical, because in the force
of evolution, you
have to change things
in very peculiar, subtle
ways to make things work.
You couldn't just redo the
whole system from scratch.
But this is certainly
a logical one,
and I'll explain it to
you in just a minute.
OK, so now what we do
next is that again, we
have the two lateral
geniculate nuclei,
but now these are
in the thalamus.
These two nuclei have
grown tremendously in size,
and became much more important
in visual processing,
as did, then, the cortex.
This process, by the way,
is called encephalization.
So in primitive animals, they
have a very small cortex.
And then the course of
evolution, the cortex
grew, and grew,
and grew, and grew,
and became a more
and more important
structure in being able to
analyze just about anything,
and certainly analyze vision.
Now here we have a cortical
area in the posterior part
of the brain, as I pointed
out to you the last time.
And what you have
is a whole series
of visual areas in the cortex.
The most central
one, I guess, would
be area V1-- the so-called
primary visual cortex to which
the lateral geniculate
projects most profusely.
Then we have a whole bunch
of other visual areas,
as we'll discuss in
more detail later on.
And then what happens is that
we have several other cortical
areas.
The cortex-- I
think you all of you
know that-- is divided
into four lobes, OK?
The frontal, temporal,
parietal, and the rear one
is called the occipital lobes.
All right, now the visual
areas that you see in the back
here make extensive
interconnections
and connections to these
other lobes in the brain
to be able to analyze
the visual scene.
Now in addition,
what we have still--
as we had in more
primitive animals--
we have a superior colliculus--
actually two of them,
one on each side-- and then
we have another set of areas
called the terminal
nuclei, the nucleus
of the optic tract,
about which we will just
talk a little bit,
because they are
specializing in certain
visual functions,
but not nearly as compelling
and interesting as the work that
has been done in
the cortical areas
and in the superior colliculi.
So this is the arrangement.
But now we want to
understand, why do you
have this strange
connection here?
So to understand that, what
we are going to talk about
is the so-called horopter
or the Vieth-Muller circle.
Now what is that?
Some clever guy came up
with this observation.
They made a circle that
goes through the nodal point
of the eye.
And its diameter depends
on where you're fixating.
So fixating here, in
this case, the red area,
which is your left
visual hemifield,
impinges on the nasal
retina of the left eye
and the temporal retina
of the other eye.
So if you have an
object here, that
hits corresponding retinal
elements in the two eyes.
And that is a basic rule.
Anywhere along this
horopter, a spot
will activate corresponding
regions in the two eyes.
And then what happens is that
those corresponding points
go to the same location in the
lateral geniculate nucleus,
and in the superior colliculus,
and in the visual cortex.
So the logic of
this arrangement is
to be able to have the
two eyes have input
to corresponding
points in the brain.
That way, you can see
something uniform and clear,
rather than seeing double.
So that is, then,
the arrangement
that you have in primates.
Now just to anticipate a
little bit-- whenever images
fall inside or
outside the circle,
they do fall on
non-correspondent points,
and that will have
something to do.
And I keep you just curious
about that for the time being,
about how we process depth.
And that is a mechanism
that is involved,
so it's called stereopsis.
I've mentioned that very
briefly the last time.
OK, so that then summarises
the basic connections
of the system.
And then what we
are going to do next
is we're going to
go to the retina,
and look at in more detail
about how the retina is made.
And then we will go
in successive steps
to higher areas, sometimes
going back and forth,
to try to understand visual
processing in general.
All right, so now let's
begin by looking at the eye.
Now I don't expect you to
know all these names here,
but you should remember, of
course, the lens, the cornea.
You know that already.
You know the iris, right?
What's the iris?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, now
what do we base
our views on the color of
the eye when you say somebody
has blue eyes, or
somebody has brown eyes?
It's based on the fact
of what the coloring is
of the iris, all right?
Now, what's the iris?
The iris can get
bigger and smaller
to control the size of
the opening into the lens.
All right?
It's much like what you
have in cameras, where
they have the so-called
f-stop, right?
So if you have a
large number, say f/16
on a camera, that is set
to 16 if you do it manually
when it's bright out there.
But when it's dim out there,
like we have in this camera
here, we have the lens
wide open because it's
pretty dark in here.
Then you have a low f-stop,
like an f/4 or even lower,
to allow more light to come in--
more photons to enter the eye.
Now next is-- here's the lens.
And the fascinating thing about
the lens is that in the eye,
the lens is totally different
from the way it is in a camera.
Now, maybe by now
many of you don't even
know the details about a
camera, but one of the details,
of course, is that to
bring an image into focus,
you have to adjust the distance
of the lens from the film
onto which the
image projects, OK?
So the closer an image, the
further out the lens has to go.
Now, if that were the case
in animals and humans,
you would have a
super-bulging eye,
so when you look at
something closely,
the eye would go out like that.
And that would be
really disturbing.
So that is not the case,
because what happened instead
is something very clever that
you don't see in cameras, which
is that you have this lens here,
which is-- at least in younger
people-- is an organ that
can vary in thickness.
So you have here some
muscles, the ciliary muscles,
which are just the
thickness of this lens,
to allow it to focus
properly on the retina.
Now here, the
retina goes around,
is against the inner
wall of the eye.
You all know that, of course.
And to explain how this
is done, then-- very,
very crudely-- here we have it.
If you have an
object really near,
you want the lens to be
thick to properly focus
the image on the retina.
And if the image is
far, you have to thin
the lens to get the proper
focus on the retina.
So that's how the
lens works, at least
when you're reasonably young.
But then when you get
older, what happens
is that the lens
becomes progressively
stiffer and stiffer.
And because of that, you have
to start wearing glasses.
Now, in the olden
days, they used
to have lenses which came
in two parts-- bifocals.
So if you looked
in the upper part,
you could look at a distance.
If you looked in the lower
part, you could look close.
Nowadays, they have
graduated lenses,
so if you look in the upper
part, you can look far.
And if you want to
look [INAUDIBLE]
look down below, and then
you can see that in focus.
So once you get
older, these lenses
don't adjust as much--
still a little bit.
But the proof that this is
not that important, thank god,
now that we have these graded
lenses and we have bifocals--
is that a lot of
people in old age,
who develop-- and sometimes
not even in old age-- in India,
for example, there are a lot of
young kids who have cataracts.
Now what are cataracts?
Cataracts interfere with
the processing of vision
through the lens system,
and things become unclear,
because all kinds of blockage
occurs in the lens itself.
So how is that corrected?
The way that's corrected
nowadays, is that you have
what is called cataract surgery.
So what they do,
then, is they actually
literally remove the
lens from the eye,
and they put in a fixed lens
made out of plastic or glass.
And then, obviously, since
there's no adjustment,
you do have to wear glasses
to look at things far away
and look at things close.
And most of the time, those
would be graduated lenses.
And so people who
have cataract surgery
can see extremely well,
certainly a lot better
than having to try to deal with
lenses that have cataracts.
All right.
Now there's one other point
I want to make about the eye
here before we move
on-- maybe two points.
One is about this
part of the eye--
that you have here your
so-called iris, OK?
And what do you call what's
in the center of the iris?
AUDIENCE: Pupil.
PROFESSOR: Pupil, very good.
Now what is the
color of the pupil?
In most people,
it's black, right?
Why is it black?
How come the pupil is black?
Any thoughts about that?
OK, well, let me tell you.
And I think what I'll do
is actually I'll move on.
First I'll leave this unanswered
for just a few minutes.
This I've shown
you before, which
is another amazing
thing about the eye--
namely that in the
fovea, you have something
like 200,000 cones per
square millimeter-- 200,000.
As you go five degrees out,
it reduces tenfold to 20,000.
And then you go 10 degrees,
it reduces by half.
So because of this
very high density--
I've mentioned this
before-- in the fovea,
you have high acuity.
And that is one of
the prime reasons
you have to move your eye around
so that you can see things
in fine detail.
All right, so now let's
take another step here,
and look at the retina itself.
And let me first of
all point out to you,
I have reversed the image
to have it right-side up.
The light actually comes
in from the bottom,
and goes through all
these cells until it
hits the photoreceptors.
Here are the photoreceptors.
And at the closest
point to eye, what we
have is called the
pigment epithelium.
OK, so what's the
pigment epithelium?
The pigment epithelium
is a single layer
of cells that are
pigmented to such a degree
that when photons
come into the eye
and get to the
pigment epithelium,
they get absorbed just
like a black surface,
that you see as a black
surface, absorbs the photons
and doesn't reflect them.
So because of that, there's
no reflection back out.
And that explains why
the pupil looks black,
because the light that
comes into the eye
doesn't reflect back out.
Now there's a good
reason for that,
because if it were to reflect
back out, it would scatter,
and it would activate many
more photoreceptors receptors
than it should, and because of
that, you get blurred vision.
Now how do we know this?
Can you think of any
one species of animal
where the pigment
epithelium is not black?
AUDIENCE: In cats.
PROFESSOR: OK, in cat, OK.
So there's some
animals, you see mostly
in animals that specialize
in nocturnal vision, that
have a pigment epithelium
which actually has purposefully
reflecting molecules in it.
For them, this is called,
actually, the tapetum.
And the purpose of that
is to improve the ability
to see so that the photons
activate the photoreceptors not
only in one direction, but
also when they bounce back.
Now the tapetum is arranged in
such a way, in most animals,
that it doesn't freely
scatter the light,
but scatters in a fairly
directional manner.
And because of that,
you can see pretty well.
Now I'm sure that many
of you have noticed
that when you drive at
night, in a the deserted area
in the United States-- which
are decreasing, of course--
you can see sometimes
deer on the highway,
or rabbits for that matter.
And when you see them,
it looks like they
have two flashlights
projecting at you.
It's almost scary.
But it also helps you by being
able to avoid hitting them.
Now that's because they have
that reflecting tapetum,
all right?
Let's look at a
different example.
What other human can you
think of who does not
have a black pigment
epithelium or for that matter,
some animals as well.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Albino.
PROFESSOR: Very good-- albinos.
Now what's albinos?
Albinos are
individuals, or animals,
who lack pigment in their
skin, and, of course,
in their retinae.
So if you look at
the eye of an albino,
actually their
pupil is not black.
Their pupil is--
AUDIENCE: Red.
PROFESSOR: Reddish, very good.
Why is it reddish?
Because you have thousands
of-- in the retina,
especially mostly on the
outside here as well,
you have blood vessels.
And the blood
vessels, since they
carry blood, when light
reflects from them,
they will have a
reddish color to them,
and thereby endow, if you will,
the pupil with a reddish color.
The pupil with a reddish color.
Now, the proof that the
main function of the pigment
epithelium is to absorb the
incoming light, to prevent
scattering, is in
the fact that albinos
that lack this pigment
epithelium have
very poor vision.
They often have vision to
20 over 200 or something,
because the light scatters
from the epithelium which
is no longer pigmented
in these people,
and activates many
photoreceptors,
thereby reducing the ability to
see things clearly and sharply.
All right, so now let's go
through this retina here.
First of all, we have
the rods and the cones.
Now this brings me to a very
interesting story-- at least
for me an interesting story.
Back in the 19th century,
there was a person
whose name was Max Schultze.
I'm trying to remember
when he lived.
He lived from 1825 to 1874.
He developed some new
anatomical procedures.
And as I mentioned before,
whenever new techniques emerge
or are invented, it's
likely that you're
going to make some
interesting new discoveries.
And so he was the first person,
by then looking at the retina
and looking at the
photoreceptors,
that he said there are
two different kinds
of photoreceptors--
the rods and the cones.
The rods are sort of, like
the name implies, rods.
And the cones are sort
of, as the name implies,
conish looking.
So he looked at that and looked
at that, and said why on earth
would we have in most
animals rods and cones?
What is their function?
This was a totally
new discovery.
When he first published
this, nobody believed him.
They said, oh, they
just vary randomly,
and some are more rod-like
and some are more cone-like,
but it's just the
same photoreceptors.
So he, of course,
did not accept that.
He saw, by being very
careful about it,
that it was definitely
two different classes
just like it is in this picture.
And so he began to
ask the question, why
on earth do we have this?
So imagine yourself in
the 19th century coming up
with this incredible
discovery, and trying
to figure out why we have them.
Now if you're a
really good scientist,
then you start to
think analytically.
And so what did he do?
I'm so impressed to this day.
He said, well, let me take
a closer look at the retina
and see how the
rods and the cones
are distributed on
the retinal surface.
And he discovered, to go back to
the previous slide, that there
is a small region
here, the fovea,
where there are only cones.
There are no rods.
And I'll show you a better
picture of that in a minute.
And he said, my god,
if that's the case,
there must be something
different about the way
we see in the fovea than
we can see in areas where
you have lots of rods.
So what did he discover?
He discovered that in the fovea
we don't see too well at night.
OK, on the basis of
that, he concluded
that the rods are
for night vision.
Now this was
absolutely incredible.
There's only one sad
part in this story, which
is that this discovery was
made in the early 19th century,
but before the Nobel
Prize was initiated,
because had the Nobel Prize
been initiated before you made
this discovery,
there's no question
that he would have received
the Nobel Prize for it.
It's such an incredible
magnitude of discovery.
All right, so let's
go back here then,
and I pointed out the rods
and the cones and the pigment
epithelium.
Now let's go through
here and I'll
tell you about the
rest of the elements.
And then this time, and also
in several subsequent sessions,
we'll talk about some of these
elements in much more detail,
especially about the
retinal ganglion cells.
So anyway, when you come
here to the next stage here,
we have the so-called horizontal
cells and bipolar cells.
It's been established that
the photoreceptors connect
with both of these.
And then the bipolar cells
connect into the inner portion
of the retina, just as
I'll show you in a minute.
Now this region here
is called the OPL,
and it's easy to remember--
outer plexiform layer.
Now then, when you get into
the deeper parts of the retina,
you have the so-called amacrine
cells and ganglion cells,
and they reside in the
inner plexiform layer.
Now it is the ganglion cells
that project out of the eye
and then project,
as we had shown you,
to various regions in the
brain, most notably that we're
going to talk about today the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
Now let me also point out at
this stage to you some numbers.
Here is an enlarged, highly
simplified view of rods.
Now, the rods are constructed
in an incredibly complex way.
They have these individual
so-called disks.
And within each of these
disks-- there are about 1,000
of them-- I only have
25, here, I think, or 24.
There are about 1,000 of
these in each rod, OK?
And within each of
these disks, you
have about 10,000
rhodopsin molecules.
There are several kinds
of opsins, so-called.
Rhodopsins are the
ones you see in rods,
in there are different
kinds of opsins in cones.
And these are the photosensitive
molecules in your receptors,
so that when a photon
comes in and hits
one of these molecules,
they change shape.
And the simplest way
of thinking about this
is to say that these molecules,
these rhodopsin molecules,
come in two different shapes.
And these two different
shapes are what we call,
very simply, those
that are open and those
are the sort of
closed, if you're
describing the molecular shape.
And the easiest way to think
of them as that they're
bleached or unbleached.
And so there are millions
of these molecules,
and what is that, 10
million in each rod.
And you know how many rods
there are in the average eye?
About 120 million, and about
five or six million cones.
And you're talking about
unbelievable numbers.
It's just hard to comprehend.
But at any rate,
the molecules here,
then, are two different states--
bleached and unbleached.
What that means is
when a molecule shifts
from being unbleached
to bleached
as a result of a
photon hitting it,
that changes the overall--
I'm talking about, of course,
hundreds of molecules,
typically-- the overall degree
of de- and hyper-polarization
of the cell.
And that will then determine
whether the cell is going
to communicate to the
next elements below,
and I'll describe that in much
more detail in just a minute.
But it gives you an idea of how
unbelievably complex this is.
Yet another
complexity is that you
have this huge number of rods,
but if you think about it,
will these rods be there
in each in these rods
with each of these disks
persist for a lifetime?
So the average lifetime
is 80 or 90 years.
Well these same guys exist
in the eye all the time?
Well, the answer is no.
What happens is there is yet
another process, amazingly,
that replaces in steps these
disks in the rods, usually
a few disks every few days.
So it's a constant,
dynamic process
keeping your rods, if not your
whole body, young, so to speak.
All right, so anyway,
this gives you
sort of a crude sense of the
complexity of this system.
But now we are going
to shift over, and talk
about the retinal
ganglion cells.
And then we'll come
back, and we talk
in a bit more detail about the
preretinal ganglionic elements.
Here is a set of
pictures created
by a wonderful scientist
called [? Poyak ?], showing you
different classes of
types, if you will,
of retinal ganglion cells.
The top row here
have been named,
because of their small size
and the small dendritic arbors,
have been named midget cells.
Whereas these ones below--
some of them, at least--
are much, much bigger and have
much larger dendritic arbors,
as you can see here, have
been called parasol cells.
And why they've been
called parasol cells
I'll explain to you
in just a minute.
Now this set of pictures was
created by the Golgi stain
that I mentioned to you before,
that was invented by Golgi,
and extensively
studied by Cajal.
And for this
incredible work they
had done, a lot of
it on the retina,
they received the
Nobel Prize in 1906.
So what this disclosed,
then-- an initial view--
was that there are different
classes of retinal ganglion
cells.
And so therefore,
the big question
came up, why do we have
different classes of cells
like that, retinal
ganglion cells?
What do they do?
Well, initially
some people again--
which is good-- I
think one should
be resistant to
change and new ideas
until they are
really proven well.
Some people argue that
[INAUDIBLE] just continue,
but then it became evident
that these are indeed
different classes.
And I will present some
evidence to prove that.
So there are actually
quite a number
of different classes of
retinal ganglion cells
that perform different jobs.
We're going to try to understand
what are the different jobs
that they perform.
And we're going to
concentrate mostly
on these midget
and parasol cells,
because they are by far the
most numerous in the retina,
and make a major, major
contribution to overall vision.
All right, so now let's
look at the physiology
of retinal ganglion cells.
Now that we know we have these
different kinds of ganglion
cells, how do we find
out what they do?
Well what was recognized
in the early portions
of the 20th century was that to
find out what these cells do,
one needs to study
their activity.
And to study their
activity, what
was developed after
many different trials,
is to either record
from individual axons,
or to use a microelectrode that
you could put into the eye,
and record from individual
cells, and see what they do.
Well, the first person who
did this was Keffer Hartline.
And for the beautiful
work he had done,
he received the
Nobel Prize in 1967.
Now what he did-- he was
a tremendous surgeon.
And so what he did-- he did
this in primitive animals
like frogs-- he would
take the optic nerve,
and he would dissect one
fiber from the optic nerve,
hook it up, and record
electrically from it.
And then what he would
do, he would shine a light
into the eye, move it around
until this cell generated
action potentials.
That was just a
very small region,
because as I've
mentioned, each cell
in the retina--
each ganglion cell--
only sees a teeny, teeny, little
portion of the visual field.
So that's how he
did his experiments.
And he made some really
remarkable discoveries
which further then
were elaborated
by using slightly
different methods.
A slightly different
method, first of all,
was to put a microelectrode
into the eye.
And I've mentioned
that to you before.
The initial microelectrode
was a very fine, tube of glass
which was heated and then
pulled until the tip was only
about a micron in
diameter, which
enabled you to record from
individual cells in the retina,
or for that matter,
anywhere in the brain.
Now another change in
the methods that emerged
is that instead of shining a
light directly into the eye,
people use reflected
light, because in the world
most of what we see
is reflected light.
Of course, nowadays this
has changed a little bit,
because we have
computers and we have
TV, which were set up in
such a way as to mimic
reflected light, if you will.
But in the natural
world for the most part,
we see reflected light.
All right, so when this was
done-- this initial work that
was done by Keffer Hartline
for which he received the Nobel
Prize-- that he discovered
three major classes of cells
based on that recording
of this, which he called,
first of all, on
cells, secondly off
cells, and then
thirdly on-off cells.
Now the on cells
were those which,
when you shown light into their
so-called receptive field area,
they would discharge vigorously.
You turn the light on here, and
you can see the on cell fires.
An off cell, on the other
hand, fired when you turned off
the light using this
particular method.
And on-off cells
were those that fired
both at the onset and the
termination of the light.
And that's why they were
called, and are still
called to this day,
on and off cells.
So that was an
incredible discovery,
and has created
a major evolution
in the study of
the visual system.
All right, so now doing this
kind of work in more detail,
using especially
mostly reflected
light, several other major
discoveries were made.
A fellow at Harvard
in his later years,
originally at Johns Hopkins, did
experiments carefully studying
the receptive field
structure of these cells.
He would record, in this
case with microelectrodes,
from a single cell--
retinal ganglion cell--
and then see how it responded
when he fiddled around
with the light in
the receptive field.
So imagine, then,
that the eye is fixed.
It's looking out.
You're putting an electrode,
in this case, into the eye
or wherever you put
it, and then you
can use lights, maybe
like a projector,
move it around to find out
where the receptive field is.
And then you can present
a small spot of light,
make it a big spot, make
it different colors,
and so on, and so on.
So when this was done,
a remarkable discovery
was made by Kuffler, namely that
the so-called on and off cells
were not just responding to the
onset and termination of light.
Instead, what they did was
they responded vigorously
to a small spot in the center of
the so-called receptive field,
but if you used a
large spot like that,
there was much
less of a response.
And that was true also
for the off cells,
and for the on-off cells.
So the surround you
can think of as being
inhibitory with
respect to the center.
And so the big question
arose, why on earth
did this complex
arrangement evolve
of having cells that have not
only an excitatory center,
but also have an
inhibitory surround?
And now I'm going to let you
think about this for a minute,
and eventually I
will tell you as
to why we have
this organization.
Because we're going to
devote a whole session
to the on and off systems,
and also a complete session
to the midget and parasol cells.
And that's when we are going
to discuss this in detail.
Now, the important thing as
you learn about these things
is to be an active thinker.
And if something comes up, you
say, well, why did this happen?
Why did that happen?
Why is this?
Why is that?
When you actively
think about that,
then it becomes interesting.
And also, once the
answers come, it
becomes insightful and
exciting to understand it.
OK, so now a series
of investigators
did experiments in
which they-- this sounds
like a fairly simple
experiment-- in which they
did labeling of just the
cell bodies in the retina,
and did what is
called a whole mounts.
What's a whole mount?
You take the retina.
You flatten it out.
Then you look at this whole
layout through a microscope.
And if you label
these cells-- and this
was a so-called Nissl stain
that stains the cell bodies,
but doesn't stain the processes
like the dendrite of the axons.
What they found was-- they
did this quantitatively--
they could distinguish three
very distinct different classes
of cells.
It turned out later that
there were more than three,
but in this case, just
doing it crudely like that,
you can see those
big cells-- that one,
that one, that one, that one,
and so on-- maybe one out
of seven or eight in this
sample-- are these huge cells.
And then you have
some smaller cells.
And then you also
some tiny cells.
And if you did this
quantitatively,
they argued that they formed
distinct separate populations.
They were not a continuum.
All right, so then
that, of course,
is a basic requirement to
prove that indeed, these
are different
classes of cells that
probably perform different jobs.
So what can you do to
prove this further?
Well, subsequent to this
kind of work, people
began to look at another
interesting question about how
these retinal
ganglion cells send
a signal to the
central nervous system.
And it's been discovered,
not just in the retina,
but in many other parts of
the human and animal body,
that the rapidity with which
an axon can send its action
potentials down from one
location to the next--
from the cell body, say,
to the axon terminals--
very much depends on
the size of the cell
and the size of the axon.
So if you have a small
cell and a very thin axon,
the conduction is
slower than if you
have a big cell and a big axon.
So if that's the
case, people argued
that if you were to
take the optic nerve
and stimulate it at one
side and a little bit
down, maybe back
towards the retina,
record and see what kind
of overall general--
not action potentials, but
overall activation takes place.
And when that was done, a very
amazing discovery was made.
In this case, you can see
we have two major dips here.
This is time, OK.
Here is electrical stimulation.
Here's the activation
of hundreds and hundreds
of fibers.
And it shows that they
formed distinct groups--
a very rapidly conducting group,
a slower conducting group,
and a very slow,
more diffuse group.
So then it was subsequent--
I'll talk about that later-- it
was subsequently
established that these very
rapidly conducting axons come
from the so-called parasol
cells.
The medium conducting ones
come from the midget cells,
all right?
I'll tell you exactly
how that was established,
but now that has
become a solid fact.
OK, so now we go back to the
anatomy of these cell types,
if you look at them at
equivalent distances,
over eccentricity, one,
three, and 5.7 degrees,
here are examples
of the midget cell
dendritic orbits
[INAUDIBLE] looking straight
down at the cell.
You can see these are very
constricted dendritic orbits.
Now by contrast,
the parasol cells
have much, much larger-- three
times larger in diameter--
dendritic orbits.
And now I can tell
you-- which I deferred
before-- is that if
you look at these,
the reason they're called
parasol cells is what?
Because it looks
like an umbrella.
OK.
So this looks like an umbrella,
and of course that's parasol.
So that's why they are
called parasol cells.
And these guys, much
less interesting,
are called midget cells
because they're midget.
They're small.
All right, so that
then established--
this work was done
just 20 years ago--
it was established that you
have indeed these two very, very
distinct populations of cells.
So now the big
question came up, why
do we have on and off cells?
Why do we have midget
and parasol cells?
And as I say, we
are going to discuss
this in considerable detail.
But let me just give you
a crude introduction.
If you look at
the parasol cell--
obviously, because of the
huge dendritic orbit--
they have large, relatively
speaking, much larger receptive
fields-- three times
bigger than midget cells.
The midget cells are so
specific that each cell
in central retina gets input for
the excitatory center from just
one single cone.
Now what does that mean?
What I didn't emphasize
before, but I'm sure
you all know, that we have
three major classes of cones,
which some people call
red, green, and blue.
And then when you say that, the
real aficionados say, come on,
you can't say that.
You're supposed to say short,
medium, and long wavelength
sensitive neurons.
But we'll just call them
red, green, and blue.
Now the reason, then,
is that the center
of one class of midget cells
gets input only from red cones,
another from green cones,
and some from blue cones.
I'll show that in more
detail in a minute.
So we have these three subtypes.
And so therefore, you can
say that the midget cells,
because they're so
teeny, they should
be able to see fine detail.
And because of this
wiring, they should
be able to tell you about color.
By contrast, if you look
at the parasol cells,
they get a mix of inputs,
both in the center
and their surround,
so it's unlikely
that they can tell
you about color.
And we'll examine that's
in much more detail soon.
All right, so now the
other interesting thing
about this system is
it makes you speculate
as to why we have
them-- and we'll
elaborate on that-- is that the
midget system, when you turn
on the light, when you shine
a small spot in the center
receptive field, gives a
fairly sustained response
for the brief time that was
maybe a second of two, OK?
But the parasol system gives
you only a burst, like that,
instead of a sustained response.
So think about that.
Say why would we
have two systems
which are not only different
in size, but also different
in the profile of
their responses?
And then, once you have
this question in your mind,
then you'll be eager to find
out when we talk about that time
after next.
OK, so now let's go
back to the beginning
here, and talk about the
photoreceptors in just a bit
more detail, so you can
get a better picture of it.
Here, as I mentioned to
you before, in the fovea,
you have a very, very tightly
packed cone photoreceptors.
They're almost hexagonally
shaped rather than round,
they're so tightly packed.
But then when you
go five degrees out,
you first of all see that the
cones got to be much larger.
And now you have an intermixture
of rods there that you can see.
| in this region, you can
process both information
at low illumination levels
and high illumination levels,
whereas here as Keffer
Hartline had proven,
you can only see under fairly
bright, normal illumination
conditions.
OK, so now if you go even
further out in the retina--
this is a beautiful,
three-dimensional looking
picture-- it shows the rods
and the cones in the periphery.
There are many, many
more rods per unit area,
and the cones have
gotten even bigger.
And so obviously, the ability
for the cones to process fine
information has been
degraded as a result.
Now again, as I've
mentioned to you before,
we have in humans about 120
million rods and five million
cones in each retina.
OK, so now if you look at
the overall distribution--
this is not too
important-- you can
see that as you go
away from the fovea,
there's a very rapid decline
in the number of cones.
This is the hash line.
And then there are
no rods in the fovea,
but they increase rapidly,
and then they fall off.
So that's sort of the
overall distribution.
And therefore, you can see
fine detail in the center,
and you're very sensitive
for night vision
not in the far periphery, but
sort of in the mid section
here, anywhere between 20 and
40 degrees from the fovea.
Let me remind you, because I'm
sure you know all this already,
a few facts, OK?
I will just write down a
couple of these things.
First of all, what is
degree of visual angle?
That's a good question.
What does it mean on
the retinal surface?
Just let me give you an
interesting mnemonic.
If you stick out
your arm like that,
and you look at
your thumbnail, that
imprints one degree of visual
angle on the retinal surface.
OK?
Now we are going to talk a lot
about very small measurements.
And so when we talk
about small measurement,
I mentioned already that
the tip of a microelectrode
is about one micron.
And what is a
micron, anybody know?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: 10 to the
negative 6 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, one micron is
one-thousandth of a millimeter,
OK?
Now, talking about that in terms
of millimeters, which you're
going to do a lot-- that's the
greatest convention-- you need
to also know what is the
relationship between inches
and millimeters, centimeters?
OK, so if you take one inch--
you all know what an inch is,
I guess.
Roughly, if you look at
your thumbnail again,
it's maybe a little
bit under an inch.
Now 1 inch equals
2.54 millimeters.
So that's a very interesting
mnemonic to remember.
So whenever you look
at various things
and try to understand
size, you may
need to make that conversion,
especially if you have always
thought about things
in terms of inches.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think you
meant to write centimeters.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Did you mean
to write centimeters?
PROFESSOR: You're right, 2.5
centimeters, 254 millimeters.
You're right, OK.
Sorry about that.
Very good.
Thank you for pointing that out.
OK, so now what
we're going to do
next is we're going
to move on, and I'll
tell you another clever
experiment that had been done.
These people here,
McCrane et al.,
developed a method which enabled
them to selectively label
the blue cells in the retina.
And this shows a
picture of that.
All the rest of them
are red and green cells.
So only one out of eight
cones is in the foveal area,
near foveal area, I should
say-- this is both the fovea
and the perifovea is black.
The rest of them are
red and green cones, OK?
Now let's become
specific about the facts
here, and tell you first of all
that one degree-- roughly one
degree, which I pointed
out is like a thumb,
comprises 200 microns
on the retinal surface.
The intercone distance in the
fovea is only 2.4 microns, OK?
Whereas when you-- per
square millimeter I already
mentioned this-- you
have 200,000 cones.
You go out five degrees,
it reduces tenfold.
And then-- this I already
pointed out to you
several times.
That's a good thing to remember.
And one thing I haven't
mentioned before
is that if you look
at 12 font letter, I,
and you look at it
at 23 centimeters,
that activates about 80 cones.
So that gives you
sort of a handle
on what is the nature
of activation there.
And I already said
that several times--
namely that each rod has 1,000
disks, and each disk in it
has 10,000 molecules.
OK, and as I've just mentioned,
one out of eight cones is blue.
The others are fairly
equal in number,
but varies from
person to person.
OK, so now we are
going to tell you
about yet another experiment.
And this is an incredibly
clever experiment
that was carried out
by Ursula Drager.
At that time, when she did
this beautiful experiment,
she did this at Harvard, at
the Harvard Medical School.
And what she did was this-- she
took the words Fiat Lux, put it
on a screen, and
exposed it that too
dark to the animal-- the
animal being a mouse, OK?
And then her procedure
enabled her to label,
using a monoclonal antibody
label, those cells that
had been activated by Fiat Lux.
OK, so this is, then, the actual
retina, flat-mount retina,
showing you what
had been activated.
Now that's
remarkable, beautiful,
and she came, and
gave a talk here
at MIT maybe about 15 years ago.
And when she presented this
picture, one of the students,
it wasn't any of you, I
guess, raised her hand
and was very upset-- said, but,
but, but-- and so Ursula said,
yes?
So what do you think
this listener asked?
Well, this was a
very active thinker.
This person said, but, but,
but, was this image right-side
up on the retinal surface?
That was the question.
And Ursula Drager said,
no, it was upside down.
I just rotated it 180
degrees so you can see it.
All right, well,
interestingly enough,
there were times when
this became an issue.
First of all, before
people knew about lenses
and that lenses turn images
upside down, and secondly,
because many people
didn't believe
that the images were
upside down in the retina.
I mean, if images are
upside down in the retina,
they're upside
down on your brain,
and yet the world
is right-side up.
What's going on?
So I would say about
eight or ten years ago, I
was asked to review a paper
for a high visibility journal--
I can't name the journal-- in
which the investigator very,
very vociferously proclaimed
that we have all been wrong,
and that the images are
right-side up on the retina
after all.
So what was his proof?
His proof was that he took an
ox eye, a slaughtered ox's eye,
and cut out a little piece
in the back of the eye,
and put a translucent
piece of paper over it,
and then presented a
stimulus out there.
And when he looked at
the back of the eye,
at the translucent
part, the image
was right-side up-- a little
bit blurred but right-side up.
And so he felt that he proved
that images are right-side
up on the retina after all.
Well, I was flabbergasted.
And it took me quite
a while to figure out
why this guy got what he
got, because he'd obviously
got what he got.
So can you guys think
of any reason for this?
How come he got what he got?
AUDIENCE: Wait, what did he do?
PROFESSOR: He took the
eye, OK, and in the back,
he cut out an opening and
put a transparency over it,
so that anything
came in there, you
could see what would
have been normally
on the retinal surface.
And it was a clever experiment--
no question about that.
So what was wrong
with the experiment?
Well, I'll tell you.
What was wrong with
the experiment was
back to what I told
you before, about
the way the lens works, right?
The lens works so that when
you look at something close,
the muscles of the lens are
such that it makes the lens fat.
And when the muscles relax,
it makes the lens thin, OK?
So that means-- just to
be graphic about it--
that if you have a thick lens,
you have a short focal length.
And if you have a
thin lens, you have
a much longer focal
length, like that, OK?
So now if you look at
the back of the eye
here, where the photoreceptors
are, in this case,
it looks like it
would be upside down.
But if they were in
the same distance here,
it would be blurred and it
would remain right-side up,
just like it is with a
magnifying glass, OK?
So what this guy
didn't know is the rule
of how the muscle works in
the eye to control the lens.
And when the animal was
killed, it no longer
had the lens at the
proper focal depth.
And therefore, the
image was right-side up.
So therefore, guess
what happened?
I wrote back to this
high visibility journal
saying that this guy is
wrong for this reason.
OK, so that was certainly
an interesting experience,
and that's why I managed to
learn a little bit about how
the lens works in the eye, which
is a remarkable way it works,
since it's so totally
different from what
we are familiar with
when it comes to cameras.
OK, so now let's go to the
next step, one down from your
from photoreceptors.
And we come to the
so-called bipolar cells.
Here's a series of pictures,
the so-called [? cat ?]
bipolar cells.
And what was discovered is
that the bipolar cells here
in the outer
plexiform layer, they
connect with the photoreceptors.
And in the inner
plexiform layer,
their axonal projections are
such that in the upper layer
here, which is actually layer A,
the cells there are OFF cells.
And the ones that
project below this here
are the so-called ON cells.
So there's a separation of
the so-called ON and OFF
cells at the bipolar cell level
in the manner in which they
connect.
And so therefore, those ganglion
cells that connect with these
are OFF ganglion cells.
And those that connect with
these are ON ganglion cells.
All right, so that's
basically the bipolar cells.
And then we come to
the horizontal cells.
Here's a beautiful
example of a Procion
yellow-labeled horizontal cell.
And if that is then
analyzed in detail,
it looks something like this.
This particular cell
has 15 connections
with the photoreceptors.
And these cells-- I might
as well anticipate--
we'll talk about that
in more detail later--
they play a central
role in providing
the surround inhibition
that I described to you
for those retinal
ganglion cells.
Then if we proceed to
the amacrine cells--
and again, things
are so complicated--
the numerous, numerous amacrine
cells, different types--
and they have been
studied extensively--
they are more than 20.
And here's a clever experiment
I want to point out to you.
What you can do here, if you
look at the called cholinergic
amacrine cells-- that's one
class-- you can selectively
label them, because
they're cholinergic.
And here's an example.
All those lighter blue ones
are your cholinergic cells.
And then what you can
do, you can put this
under a microscope.
And then you can
lower a microelectrode
into one of these cells,
just like I've done here.
And if you look at
this closely-- this
is not the best
of pictures-- this
is a Procion
yellow-labeled amacrine
cell-- you can see it
has all these processes.
So then if you look at
this on the microscope
under the high quality,
you can draw these out.
And this is what
they look like, OK?
So this is a cholinergic cell.
This is another type.
It's just called A2, which
has a lot to do with rods.
And then yet another class
called open [? minergic ?].
I'm not going to go
into detail about it.
But you can see that each of
these now-- scientific methods
enable you to specify what
these amacrine cells are like.
And on the basis of
that, people have come up
with ideas what the
amacrine system does.
OK, now we come to the crux of
things in the last few minutes.
We're going to talk about
the electrical responses
in the retina.
Now this is going to be,
again, fairly complicated.
This work-- again remarkable
work which, in my view,
merits a Nobel Prize,
but it has not yet
been awarded to John
Darling at Harvard.
And let me just introduce
this by telling you
how they went about
this experiment.
They realized that the
cells in the retina
are very, very small.
And so it's very difficult
to record from them
intercellularly.
You have to do that
if you want to be
able to label them anatomically.
And so they looked around
for a species of animal
that had large
cells in the retina.
And they discovered
after a lot of search
that the so-called mudpuppy--
Necturus maculosus--
is an animal that has unusually
large retinal ganglion cells.
Then they developed a
technique of removing the eye
from this animal, and
putting it into a dish,
because that makes
it real stable.
And then they were able to
put an electrode in there,
define what the cells did
functionally by shining light
on them and looking
at the activity,
and then they were
able to label the cell
by injecting a
labeling substance.
So that's what they did.
And so here is a description
of that arrangement.
Here you have an
inverted mudpuppy retina,
and here you have a
DC-recording electrode.
And what you do then, you
look at it in an oscilloscope.
And at this point, the cell is
entered by the DC recording.
And then once it's
inside, cells inside
are negatively charged with
respect to the surround,
usually up to about
70 millivolts.
In this case, I have
50 millivolts labeled.
And so once you're
inside the cell,
you see a sudden drop
to a minus level.
And then if the cell
discharges an action potential,
then you see that, of
course, in the oscilloscope.
And then you can study this
cell in all kinds of detail
as to how it responds,
what it responds and so
on, to determine what
its characteristics are.
So then when they
did that, they made
the following
central discoveries--
they discovered, first
of all, that receptors
all hyperpolarize to light.
Now this is the opposite of
what you would have thought,
because the principle
of the way cells
operate-- and I'm sure
you know all this,
but I will also describe
it in a bit more detail
in a minute-- cells
when they hyperpolarize,
they are less likely to cause
a release in neurotransmitters.
If they depolarize, they
will increase the likelihood
of neurotransmitters
being released.
And by the way, the
neurotransmitter
for these receptors
is glutamate.
And also, which I
should emphasize here,
is that the receptors never
give action potentials.
They only give
graded potentials.
That's also true for
the horizontal cells
and the bipolar cells.
They found that all of receptors
hyperpolarize to light, meaning
that they activate subsequent
elements in the retina
when it gets darker
out there, rather than
when it gets lighter, which
is the opposite of what we all
would've expected.
Same thing for the
horizontal cells.
But then when you
come to bipolar cells,
suddenly you find that there
are two different classes-- one
class which mimics
what the receptors do,
the other class that
does the opposite.
And so the bipolar cells
of these two types--
this type has sign
conserving synapses,
and this type has sign
inverting synapses.
Now amacrine cells
come in various types,
and some give action potentials.
And ganglion cells all
give action potentials.
So to go through this
again, all receptors
hyperpolarize to light.
Horizontal cells
About half of bipolar cells
hyperpolarize and half
depolarize.
Now this is
accomplished-- by the way,
I'll go into that in
more detail later--
by virtue of having different
kinds of neurotransmitter
receptor sites.
And I'll talk about
that in a lot of detail
when we talk about
the ON and OFF cells.
OK, and then we have
the amacrine cells.
Some hyperpolarize, some
depolarize, and some
give action potentials.
And all ganglion cells
So that is a major, major
discovery, and not only major,
but totally unexpected from
what one would have thought.
All right, so now
let me just explain
this in a bit more detail.
If you go inside a cell, then
if this cell is activated,
it can be either
get-- what you see
is an excitatory post
synaptic potential, which
goes from minus
towards plus, or you
can get an IPSP, an inhibitory
post synaptic potential.
And this discovery
was made by Eccles,
which is a remarkable discovery
for which he received the Nobel
Prize some years back.
All right, so now if we look at
those cells which give action
potentials, what happens is
when you get an EPSP-- that's
why it's called excitatory
post synaptic potential-- then
you increase the likelihood
that an action potential
will be generated that
will send its signal down
the axon to the next
location of the cells.
All right, so that's
the basic process.
So again to reiterate,
photoreceptors
hyperpolarize the light.
Therefore, glutamate
is released when
there's a decrease in
illumination-- the opposite
of what anyone
would have expected.
All right, so that
I think brings us
to what I want to cover today.
I'll wait until
next time to talk
about the lateral geniculate
nucleus, which is very brief.
But let me go through the
four receptor basics again.
All photoreceptors
hyperpolarize the light.
Depolarization of
the photoreceptor
releases glutamate.
Photon absorption by the
photo pigment results
in isomerization of the
chromophore from 11 cis
to 11 trans.
This is what I told you
to think about in a very
simple fashion-- to say that
the photoreceptor molecules--
rhodopsin in this case-- is
either bleached or unbleached,
OK?
So once it's bleached, further
light has no effect on it.
And at any point, given whatever
the level of illumination is,
a certain percentage of
these rhodopsin molecules
are bleached and a certain
percentage is unbleached.
The darker it is, the
more are unbleached.
All right, then we
have these two classes
that we talked about--
the ON and the OFF cells
that we will discuss in some
detail-- the synaptic junction
of OFF bipolars is sign
conserving, as I just said,
and that of ON bipolars
is sign inverting.
Now the ON bipolar receptor
is-- I should mention that now,
and I will deal with it in
detail-- is called the mGluR6.
It's activation leads
to closing of channels
causing hyperpolarization.
that's the basic layout,
then, of the photoreceptors.
And I will now
stop at this point.
And next time, we'll
talk a little bit
about the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
And then we're going to move
on to talk about the cortex.
then if you look at
you assignment sheet,
you can see here that
on September 16th,
we're going to talk about
the ON and OFF channels.
And then we'll deal in more
detail with these rather
complex things which are
pretty hard to remember,
about hyperpolarization,
depolarization, glutamate,
glutamate receptor
sites, and so on.
OK, thank you.